[Música]
ustedes cuando niños o adolescentes
alguna vez anhelaron conocer el paraíso
pues yo sí y no sabía que el paraíso se
encontraba tan cerca de donde yo vivo
soy andrea tengo 29 años y vio en villa
maría del triunfo desde que nací durante
mi etapa escolar en secundaria visitaba
todos los años las lomas de mi distrito
a través del curso de educación física
que llevaba en el colegio a hablar de
lomas en lima una ciudad construida
sobre un desierto en donde la mayoría de
los cerros son de piedras y tierra seca
es hablar de un oasis de un área natural
que sólo florece o reverdece en invierno
y donde puedes respirar vida sin embargo
no tengo gratos recuerdos de aquellas
épocas porque las visitas serán siempre
en invierno y la verdad hacía demasiado
frío en las lomas además en aquel
entonces no me gustaba caminar tramos
tan largos ni zonas de alta pendiente
aún así durante las caminatas recuerdo
que siempre observaba gran cantidad de
plantas y animales silvestres pero como
no recibía información sobre el lugar
que recorríamos no no era tan fácil
generar un vínculo con ese espacio y
como no entendía lo que veía tampoco era
relevante para mí
tiempo después acabe el colegio y decidí
estudiar administración de turismo
durante la carrera viaje y visité muchos
lugares entre ellos lomas de lúcumo y
lomas de lachay
y recuerdo que cuando fui siempre hubo
alguien que me guiaba en el recorrido y
que me contaba sobre todo lo que podía
observar y yo veía la riqueza que tenía
ante mis ojos y por eso la valoraba de
hecho siempre pensaba qué suerte que
tienen aquellas personas que viven cerca
de un lugar así
después cuando acabe la acabe la de la
universidad llegó el momento tan ansiado
de hacer la tesis de buscar información
buscar temas escuchar sugerencias y en
es en ese momento es que un familiar me
contó acerca de unas lomas que había
visitado me dió mucha curiosidad así que
me animé y decidí ir y es así como
llegué a las lomas de paraíso una área
natural ubicada a unos 20 minutos
aproximadamente en carro de donde yo
vivo y fue increíble mi sorpresa al
darme cuenta que había vuelto a aquel
lugar que yo visitaba en mi etapa
escolar pero esta vez como había
estudiado turismo había visitado otras
lomas y sobre todo les había valorado ya
la miraba con otros ojos me percaté del
gran potencial que tenía este espacio
en el distrito y por primera vez me
sentí orgullosa de ser villa mariana
pero a la vez me sentí triste porque
había visto tantas veces este lugar y
nunca lo había valorado y yo me
preguntaba por qué no lo había valorado
pues porque nadie me enseñó nadie nunca
me explicó de la importancia de estas
lomas y como les dije hace un momento es
muy complicado relacionarse o vincularse
con algo que tú no entiendas y eso es lo
que nos pasa a la mayoría de los jóvenes
hoy en día que desde pequeños no nos
enseñan a amar lo que tenemos y por eso
crecemos con muy poquita identidad local
y terminamos destruyendo lo que es
nuestro y además aquello que nos brinda
beneficios como es el caso el claro
ejemplo de las lomas
meses después ya de mi primer
reencuentro con las lomas de mi distrito
en el año 2015 decidí participar de una
convocatoria de voluntariado que
organizaba la asociación de lomas de
paraíso
pero esta vez ya no solo promovida por
mi interés en la tesis sino también por
mi deseo de contribuir desde mi
profesión a la conservación de este
espacio y también con generar en las
personas que visitan las lomas es el
vínculo que yo construí tarde
es así que desde aquella convocatoria
hasta el día de hoy participó de esta
organización
a pesar de que en un inicio mi familia y
mis amistades no estuvieron tan de
acuerdo con mi participación me decían
qué hago yo perdiendo mi tiempo yendo a
esos cerros me decían que cuál es la
necesidad mía no de tomar y asumir tal
responsabilidad y de dedicarle tanto
tiempo de esfuerzo
actualmente soy orientadora turística y
formo parte de la junta directiva de
dicha asociación la cual está formada
por vecinos y vecinas de tres
asentamientos humanos eran del manantial
bellavista y quebrada al está el paraíso
quienes la tienen muy clara que
conservar las lomas contribuye a
combatir el cambio climático porque
disminuye los impactos de la radiación
solar regula el clima y purifica el aire
lo cual tanta falta nos hace en
villamaría puesto que somos uno de los
distritos más contaminados contaminados
en lima según la organización mundial de
la salud debemos tener 8 metros
cuadrados de área verde por habitante
pero en villamaría no llegamos ni el
metro cuadrado para el año 2018 se ha
perdido el 40% de cobertura de lomas y
todo esto se debe al tráfico de terrenos
que ha causado un daño significativo a
las lomas en el año 2017 en una
entrevista realizada a un ex
representante el ministerio del ambiente
indica que el principal problema de
villamaría es la escasez de áreas verdes
entonces yo me pregunto si ese es
nuestro problema no podemos permitir
el tráfico de terrenos siga causando
tanto daño en su ecosistema y que nos
quite este recurso tan importante para
todos los limeños por eso hoy más que
nunca creemos que es importantísimo a
trabajar en la conservación de las lomas
y sobre todo en generar vínculos entre
la gente y su entorno natural para que
para que puedan conocer entender y
valorar este ecosistema
por eso nuestro proyecto comunitario
nace con la finalidad de conservar las
lomas de nuestro distrito a través del
desarrollo del ecoturismo una actividad
económica de bajo impacto para la
naturaleza que busca sensibilizar y
educar al visitante y a la población
local sobre la importancia de proteger
estas lomas para que así este ecosistema
nos continúe brindando los beneficios
que tanto necesitamos y a la vez poder
promover el empleo y los emprendimientos
en las poblaciones aledañas que les
permita y ayude a mejorar su calidad de
vida hoy la niña andrea cuenta con el
apoyo de su familia quienes comprenden y
entienden su labor y lucha mi mayor
sueño es que cada vez más jóvenes puedan
encontrar y vincularse con su paraíso
así como yo lo hice con el mío y que
además se sumen a la conservación de
nuestras áreas naturales
de manera conjunta con la comunidad
desde el espacio que sea a través de
acciones voluntarias por más pequeñas
que puedan está hacer para que así
juntos podamos demostrar que sin jóvenes
no hay paraíso